it's probably like nuclear fusion you
know you ask people when will the first
nuclear fusion power be available and
the answer is always in 50 years time
and the answer is and when will there be
genuinely intelligent machines well I
might be very wrong here but some pop to
my cell within 10 years I would say well
maybe it's 50 years maybe it will always
be 50 years I just do not know Turing
was fascinated with the idea of how
intelligent could you make a machine be
the imitation game itself was a game
Turing devised to what yes the idea was
that if you're at the other end of a
telephone line and you've got a I think
in those days of course it was a
teletype or a dumb terminal you know and
you type questions at something and the
answer comes back and if after an agreed
period of time you're then asked was
that a human you were talking to or was
it a machine if you can't decide that
it's not human then it's passed the test
it's masqueraded as a human I think what
he realized all the long as perhaps
teasing as a little and it's always
seemed to me is that with a limited
bandwidth for interaction like that it's
very probably one of Turing's own
undecidable problem you can't get enough
information to come to a rational
decision as to whether it's a human or a
machine but this doesn't stop there
being I think is this ride there's a
yearly competition now they normally
give scores like you know sixty percent
thought it was human 40 percent thought
it was machine the answer is it's
machine and stuff like that to me you
see it really is it as I was saying a
case of undecidability if you need to
visit the other end of the line and see
whether there's somebody typing teletype
to come to a decision but then of course
that spoils the whole nature of the test
it was a topic that fascinated children
and one that he really really cared
about and it's interesting had he lived
I'd love to know what he makes of the
present day artificial intelligence
scene and just what is easy to do in the
AI field and what is hard and my own
observation and I'm not an expert so
I expect to be put in my place and told
our Royale is that the computer could do
a fixed task in a narrow domain very
differently to a human and be superb at
it example chess absolutely superb
example I think Dee Bloo be Kasparov way
back when but it absolutely did not use
the pattern matching analysis type thing
the grandmaster would do its brute force
you know the whole game tree as it were
chess if I do this don't do that then do
that I mean your average chess player
might be able to look six or seven moves
ahead over all possibilities
blasted deep blue can go i Lord knows
how many moves ahead and actually this I
think is is a good example R of this
because what grandmasters were missing
and actually what I think ken Thompson's
chess machine Bell helped to fill in is
he I think he did all five piece endings
or something like that and the ones that
the grandmasters didn't know about
because they needed tons of look at I
think that is right
is the ones way you absolutely do
something stupid you go miles or what
here and and the rest and saying don't
do that no no you don't do that this
machine stupidest gonna lose its gonna
lose you know then right at the very end
a tiny little thing that nobody had
noticed and from the absolute depths of
near defeat he suddenly finds a sneaky
little way to make this pawn do that
manner before we know where you are it's
a squeaker narrow victory in only 10,000
moves or something like that you know
I'm exaggerating but you get the idea
that it's those where you would have to
go miles away from the solution into an
area where human said there's no hope
it's everything's lost but it isn't
there's a sneaky little alley way
through to getting a victory that's the
kind of things a machine can do but a
human card is the Traveling Salesman
from where there are so many
possibilities but a human would just
look at an app and go well I'm going to
try that well there is a connection
there is an interesting one too you're
quite right that it's one of these
classic np-complete problems you
it is believed that there is no way to
get the perfect answer
then simply to look at every single
possibility and the monumental way the
combinations of those add up is just
mind-boggling however what I think
people in the field will tell you is
there is a very good set of algorithms
which will give you a pretty darn good
answer even though it might not be
absolutely perfect and that's the
differences between you know good enough
within five or six percent of the best
verses must be absolutely the best route
so that caliban's do backgrounds that a
whole human versus computer
touring thing which is if I'm on the end
of the phone or the teletype and I say
I'd know what color is music yeah this
is the problem about that Turing test
game you know you could get either end
of the equation trying to play silly
games I think there was a program called
Perry probably invented was it a
Stanford somewhere in America
Perry was going to replicate the speech
patterns of a paranoid schizophrenic you
say and you can imagine if you're up
against that and you don't know whether
the other end is actually a real
schizophrenic person or a program
simulating that behavior that is far
harder to tell the difference or on
because you know you you ask some
perfectly ordinary question like what is
2+2 I don't know why you're focusing on
- it's my hating number and all this
kind of stuff it makes it very very
difficult to start saying that is a
human but one with a mental problem
versus that is a program that's
simulating that sort of thing so I think
it's it's the thing that AI always runs
into is this that getting a part way
answer but by very different routes than
a human would I'm giving you enough
information about navigating to a town
to be useful fine is when you start
wanting total perfection and fantastic
subtlety but because things fall apart
because that's the thing as well
ambiguity that humans are accustomed to
and the idea of inflection in time
yeah so for instance ok Google how do
you pronounce something in a hungarian
so it's given us the word for something
garyun and bless it it's told us it
pronounced it like this follow me but
I'm being more general about it so I
want to know how can Gary's pronounce
things on beer fabulous things like
ambiguity and use of similes and
metaphors is a classic for throwing
things off there's a real classic from
the seventies I think it is is you know
her okay
artificial intelligence program analyze
the difference between time flies like
an arrow and fruit flies like a banana
now that's a beauty because you know
time flies like an arrow it's a simile
and all this kind of thing extension of
a metaphor but on the other hand the
other one which on the surface go very
similar grammatical structure
time flies is a noun phrase like ah it's
not like you've been used in the similar
sense it's like is a joy and they're
clearly
eating a banana you say now it's that
kind of subtlety and that kind of
knowledge of how the real world works
allied to syntactic analysis that's what
you and I use all the time you know and
what computer systems would find so very
very difficult but of course you're
inviting the computer program to sort of
say hey there must be a thing called a
time fly and they live on an exclusive
diet of adverts oh yeah we know that's
impossible so see we're using that kind
of knowledge over this whole domain of
what the real world is like in order to
disambiguate between those two all the
successes of artificial intelligence
tend to be a narrow domains you know if
you're like say playing chess is one
example there's a thing they did at
Stanford
Mison I think it was about antibiotics
and their effect and the great advantage
goes whether you with a computer is if
it is all done by logic then it will do
it and it will
get tired and it will not usually make
mistakes unless you're counting up
Gangnam style hits but that's the point
you know you don't get bored you don't
make mistakes if your computer so
therefore that's why they often
outperform humans roger penrose very
famous mathematician at oxford got
really rather hot under the collar about
all this think you wrote a book called
something like the emperor's new mind
had a real go at artificial intelligence
basically said the trouble is you're
assuming that the human brain is just
like a very complex Turing machine what
I am convinced it's more than that i
roger penrose think there are quantum
effects and if only my neurological
medical friends would tell me how to
find them and how to categorize them I
may be able to tell you more about the
computational model that is really going
on in the human brain but I've not read
anything about that recently so it's on
the to-do list I think
friendly environment by enveloping
around the agent in question Lemaitre
every time that had got up to nine it
would nudge the dial to the left of it
to move on one plus they get stuck in
what's called a local maximum or a local
minimum on the left will be 2 to the
power zeros